All right, it's time for Drew's News.
Your daily news stir fry with that good news sizzle.
And here with me is my trusty co-pilot,
Rossy Ross Mathews.
Hi, everybody!
Hey, Drew.
(audience clapping)
I know.
I love you.
We're starting with the Beautiful Issue
of "People" magazine.
Everybody gets so excited with that.
And guess what?
Oh look, yes.
It's none other than Dame Helen Mirren.
There's also a really special story inside
that continues to celebrate women.
It gives a little inside look
into the favorite besties for all of us, Oprah and Gayle.
They're finally telling their origin story
of the beautiful friendship
that we've all come to know as, "That's my Gayle."
It all started 46 years ago on a snowy night in Baltimore.
Oprah was 21, Gayle was 22.
And the two young newsies
were following their dreams at WJTZ-TV.
And then, this blizzard hit and Oprah invited Gayle over
and they were like up all night chatting.
They had this great kind of evening
that the weather brought them together
and the rest is history.
You just never know
when you're gonna meet your next bestie.
You know, I've met besties poolside.
I've met 'em at a bar.
I've met 'em at this very desk right here.
Aw!
You never know
when you're gonna meet a bestie.
Think about that.
Who could you meet next
and they could be your next best friend?
I love that idea.
All right, next, we've got women bringing major changes
to the MLB in today's Sports! Sports! Sports!
Been too long
since we've done sports.
Gives me withdrawals.
I know.
We need it back.
Well, "The Wall Street Journal" reports
this season there's a new record in baseball.
Listen to this, 11 of the on-field coaches
across the Majors and Minors are women.
Yep.
(audience cheering)
It's pretty amazing.
Yeah, Drew, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put this into perspective a little bit,
since 2018, as recently as that,
there have been zero, there were zero female coaches
and now there's 11.
That's so crazy.
That's just four years ago.
Yes.
So think about where we could be four years from now.
That's what I like to think about.
Double it, 22.
Hello, triple it.
(audience clapping)
Let's shout out some of these coaches.
This season, Alyssa Nakken became the very first woman ever
to coach an MLB game for the Giants.
By the way, she looks so cool.
Right, and the Yankees just promoted
Rachel Balkovec to manager
of the Tampa Tarpons.
Yes!
She's the first woman to lead a team in the Minors.
And, MLB, we say keep it up.
That's how you play ball.
Yes, please.
Yes, that's exactly right.
Mhmm.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)